so I metrica a Buddhist monk and live
since 40 years in the Himalayas and the
French interpreter for the dilemma so
let me hand of us which is but
surprising for a Buddhist monk but what
I think we can contribute is to realize
as Gandhi said that there is enough for
everyone's need but there is not enough
for where everyone's greed and i think
one lesson that the present crisis can
teach us is that just the pursuit of
selfish happiness is bound to fail
especially when is connected with greed
and the lesson that we can take from
this crisis is that we need to work for
towards a more altruistic society while
twisted in dealing with people's
investment not play like if you were
doing at the casino be more concerned
and altruistic for people's flourishing
in life consider where they work the
environment and more twisted for future
generation about taking care of the
environment so it seemed that altruism
on the moralistic society is the single
answer to all those three times care and
that is not a sort of fascism a topic or
idealist view but it's really attuned to
the interdependence of the world so if
you can understand in globalization as
interdependence and seek a win-win
situation the sort of exploiting others
I think we will have taken serious
lessons from these economic crisis